two one nine two david p is our
voicemail number many people have
emailed me
people are talking wondering if the
kansas troll is still alive because we
haven't heard from him for so long what
we have now heard from him and the
kansas troll called in to defend nazi
mentality not nazi ideology and to fight
back against what he describes as nazi
phobia take a listen to this I'm very
tired David mister pac-man yeah you're
not Cecilia yeah I'm a peaceful neo-nazi
my chosen ideology may be hateful but
I've never attacked anyone I don't
destroy property I'm a threat to anyone
there are many neo-nazis in the world
and only a tiny minority of them engage
in violent extremism like most Nazis
just want to be left alone as well my
deeply held beliefs may not be your cup
of tea mister pac-man but they are my
belief hmm and diversity is our strength
just because we have different opinions
it doesn't mean that my opinion is wrong
as a neo-nazi hmm and I shouldn't have
to be afraid of walking down the street
in addition to that this is a tolerant
society that we are living in and I am
deserving of tolerance as a Nazi
like anyone else is deserving of
tolerant riots you don't like it move
somewhere where that kind of intolerance
would be accepted
yeah not all Nazis and not the phobias
right uh I mean it you taking the term
troll really too it's it's full and and
paper definition uh the kansas troll is
back i don't know if you were worried
about the kansas troll no and now i know
he's back but you can tell that some
serious level trolling when when you
look at his cadence cuz there are some
long pauses where he has to think
through yeah thinking oh it's our total
and utter trolling yet but anyway people
worried about the kansas troll he is
alive and seemingly well on the bonus
show today we will talk about a black
woman accused of stealing leading to a
Victoria's Secret kicking out all black
customers from their store we will also
talk about a completely logical decree
from the Denver mayor about the blankets
belonging to homeless P
in the middle of winter and much more
david pakman.com slash members
membership and of course david
pakman.com slash donate the indiegogo
crowdfunding campaign is on check it out